hi everybody my name is Ellie or I'm a
data scientist at data science group and
I'm gonna be talking about notes avec
which is an algorithm for embedding or
creating dense representations for nodes
and edges and any given graph it's one
in something year old algorithm Kalyan
came out in 2016 and out of Stanford
from Grover - Kovach and the agenda is
gonna be we're gonna start up with what
actually no Tyvek tries to do then we're
gonna go over a little bit about how it
does it and that's actually the most
important part and we're gonna finish
with a showcase which is coupled with a
Python notebook which you can all like
reproduce the results at home with a pip
installable library with the implemented
the the notes of a Cal gorilla so let's
start so let's take for example a very
simple graph right the this will be the
example graph the note colors have no
meaning whatsoever but I want you to
think about the edges as smaller the
edge is be higher the way right so we as
humans when we see a graph like that
it's like very clear to us a lot of
information about the graph we can exact
immediately see by the closeness of the
the edges that there's two kind of
groups here and we can also understand
that like node BT node a which is gate
to the outside world has the same
relationship that no 2 has 2 node 1 now
this is information that for us comes
very natural when we look at graphs or
when we think about graphs but when we
want to use graph data in downstream
tasks in our models or any other things
that we want to build upon it we have to
find a way to take that information and
pass it on to our models because if we
don't do so if we will just use you know
like any kind of one heart
representation for notes or what else we
put the burden
learning these relationships on the
model itself so we want to make our
models tasks easier by giving this
information so what not affect what's
tries to achieve is to embed that
information into some kinds of space
that will encapsulate all that
information so this what note effects
tries to do it tries to take the nodes
that are actually close together in the
graph that are strongly connected and
create closeness in the embedded space
and it will also try to make the
relationship or the vector that points
from vector a 2 vector B the same or
very similar to the vector that points
from node 1 to node 2 so this is what no
Tyvek tries to achieve so how it does
how does it do that
before I go to the next slide I think
it's best to explain notes avec through
note to it through world Tyvek okay
because no Tyvek actually builds upon
the successful foundations of words avec
word server came out two years before
that and actually changed a lot of the
NLP world and has had a lot of success
in in various fields so it's only
natural that other algorithms will build
upon it so if we will think about how
our words avec works in like a modular
way we're not going to go very deep into
that because it's out of the scope of
this talk but in a modular way words
avec takes is an input and array of
sentences and what it does it generates
from data rate of sentences some kind of
input data to what is called the skipper
model this data is get fed to the Skip
grow model and from that skipper model
we then draw the embeddings so you might
ask like okay what's effect it's nice
but what does that has to do with with
graphs and nodes and no to that so we
have a problem that is already solved we
know how to acceptances and embed them
so if it would find a magical way to
take a graph and reduce it into
sentences we will actually solve our
problems so now we started with
embedding
Raph's now we our problem is like a
little bit different we need to make to
take any graph and turn it into an array
of sentences so how do we do that that's
kind of weird too so let's think about
sentence what is the sentence sentence
is like a sequence of tokens and it has
a specific direction right if we we
would to read this sentence we know
where to start
okay abstraction is often one floor
above you and I sentence so we
understand the structure of this we know
the first word is obstruction and the
next word is and so on so in some kind
of way this is a specific kind of graph
right where each word is a node and the
edges are just this the the
characteristics of this sequence okay so
now now it's starting to make a little
bit of sense now we all we need to do is
to reduce the graph into this specific
in an array of this specific type of
graphs so this is the problem that note
of X secret sauce really solves it makes
it takes a graph any graph and it has
its intelligent way of creating this
array of this specific type of graphs so
how do we do that given that we are
talking about any graph it could be
directed i'm director it could be sickly
it could be weighted unweighted it can
even be unconnected you know like
separate graphs and this is done about
what is called random walks which is
quite a bad name for that because it's
not really random
we control the randomness of the of
these walks but the idea is is that
we're going to use what is called a
sampling strategy we'll which we'll talk
about in the next slide don't worry
about that we're going to use this
sampling strategy to generate random
walks from every node in the graph and
those random rocks are actually look
look like this one because when we start
from now and we start to traverse it to
another nodes we can just collect this
kind of in any kind of work so the first
worker might look like this one and the
second one would look
a little bit different and then we would
gather this all of these walks and we
basically just generated a lot lots of
sentences out of our graph okay so let's
talk about random walks and how do they
work and how we control them because
this part is are actually really
important because we control the walks
we actually control the information we
want no Tyvek together from our from our
graph so the hyper parameters are not so
many first one is the output dimension
right we're gonna embed nodes and edges
first have to decide the output
dimensions of the embeddings the next
thing is the number of walks number of
walks actually says how many time I'm
going to start a random walk from each
node in the graph the third one is the
walk length right I'm gonna start
walking from each from each no but how
long am I gonna walk so these are like
the three basic ones and then comes like
the secret sauce you might say off of
notes avec so no okay before we look at
we actually talked about the hyper
parameters when we will think about the
probability to traverse from one node to
the others the most naive way to do with
it by normalizing the weights right if
it's like I has a stronger connection it
has a higher weight it will get a higher
probability to travel from one node to
another but that doesn't give it enough
flexibility because sometimes the
weights are given so what notes of rec
offers is two additional parameters
which are controlling the search bias
the third bias is this path the the the
characters represented by the character
alpha is actually gets multiplied by the
weights and after we multiplied the
search bars by the weights we normalize
them and then we get the probabilities
of transitioning between one node to
another and and through that we control
the the way we which route so let's
explain the two the two these two
parameters first one is the peep
parameter with the return however
parameter
and consider this this like small sample
of a graph when we just started a walk
and we transitioned from t2v
right so we're in V and we came from T
the p-value which is the return a hyper
hyper parameter controls the likelihood
that we're going to go back from VT t if
we set a low P parameter we increase the
probability to return back and actually
we just say I want to emphasize the
connections on the local loop see like
at the graph could be huge I want to
emphasize the local structure of the
graph so that's the P return hyper
parameter the Q actually controls what
you might think about if we're going to
be traveling on the graph in a BFS way
or a DFS way so imagine that we set a
very high Q value we will actually lower
the probability to go deeper we will
favor a BFS like search than a DFS kind
search and we will say to a very low
value then we will increase the the
importance of global structure in the
graph and encourage exploration
throughout the entire graph so this is
like really important to understand this
jointly with what the scraper model of
words iveco really embeds which I do
have a link on Bill on the last slide
that I do encourage anybody that doesn't
understand skip your model to read about
because it's it's very important to
understand what kind of information the
Skip gram embeds in order to use note
effect to its fullest so now we know how
to create a sentences we basically know
all the process that note effect does
and let's see a use case of how we
control the the graph and its structure
to eventually decide what information we
want to embed so the Showcase is gonna
be on the FIFA 17 data so part of my
geekiness but I'm a FIFA player so this
is what I chose it's actually available
on cargo it's a
a bunch of tables representing is a team
structural from various clubs in that
are playable in FIFA so what does like
football team has to do with graphs any
team is represented by a formation right
any team has like a striker a left
winger central midfielders stuff like
that and they are connected in some kind
of way now there's a dozen of different
formation connected in different ways
there are dozens different different
players and teams and each one is
connected in a different way so in order
to do this showcase which as I said you
can later find on the notebook first of
all it's trying to think what we are
trying to achieve so we are going to
have three types of nodes we're going to
have player nodes which are like
Cristiano Ronaldo Messi all those type
of guys we're going to have team notes
which represent the team itself like
Madrid Barcelona etc and the last type
of note is going to be a generic
position like a central midfielder
central back a goalkeeper and so on and
the idea is what we are trying to
achieve is something that - assuming it
comes very naturally right we if I ask
you like what is most similar to a
goalkeeper you can name
goalkeepers from different teams now so
you want to embed in the space if I will
ask you who is the most similar player
to Paolo Di Bella I would expect you to
say players that play like around him
and can exchange him he in the field so
this is the kind of information we're
going to try to embed so how are we
going to do that how are going to
construct our graph first we're gonna
take each team and create specific
player notes given that team so like
this could be aa Cristiano Ronaldo this
could be the one who plays beside him
and all of them are going to be
connected to the team note I didn't I
didn't draw that because it will be very
quiet in a mess and we're gonna do that
to any team in our data I did
specifically on seven clubs so any any
team is going to be connected between
itself - according to the formation and
we're going to add the we're gonna every
grand
to be adding the generic the generic
notes so these generic notes are also
connected by the damn country I did
include the edges so I will be able to
explain what's going on and the last
type of connections we're going to be
making is connecting between the actual
themes and the generic positions so the
central midfielder since he is connected
to his central back cm2 and cb2 cb2 he
is gone he is also gonna be connected to
their general to the generic positions
and you will see in a minute why that is
important to embed the information we
talked about and similarly to the
goalkeeper so now we're going to start
the random walks and let's consider how
many ways there to get from SC m2 into G
k2 on the right side T so one way would
be cm - through the generic position to
the goalkeeper the second way to do that
will be through the literal central back
so what have we done here when we look
at these two sentences right we can see
that the generic position CB which is in
yellow actually gets the same context as
CB - and by creating these kinds of
walks we are basically teaching the
algorithm or giving it the ability to
learn that the central bank generic
generic position is similar to CB - why
because the appearance similar context
that's as part of the thing and if we
will do the same to this to the second
team we will actually get a connection
between the central backs of the other
teams right we can see that if sin if CB
one is similar to C B and C and C B is
similar to similar to CB 2 we will get
the result that cb1 and cb2 are really
like something like of the same and also
another thing that we gain here since we
are if we look at the first sentence and
the third one we will get that the
relationship with
when the central midfielder or cm - - GK
- is the same relationship between cm 1
and G K 1 and okay that's all hand
waving and stuff but let's see if this
actually works so this is taken from the
notebooks on some kind of results of
wearing the the space that got that was
outputted by the algorithm and the first
thing I did is like I'm taking a generic
generic position a right-winger position
and I'm looking for the most similar
nodes in the graph that to that
degenerate position and it might must be
gibberish to most of you but these are
actually right wingers right so anyone
who does know get back me up here so
these are all indeed right wingers and
the next thing we wanted to do is if I'm
app and if I'm going to query a specific
player I would expect to see his
teammates around him so the next thing
we do we're acquiring power dibala which
is a Juventus player and we can see also
the his team known here and all of the
players that play with it ok on the same
thing we're also only seeing 10 because
that's the default setting of the top
and most similar the last thing which
actually is not on the notebook I just
added it today so it's not on the
notebook but you can replicate it
yourself is the King woman king queen
woman analogy from from Ward Civic so
what I'm taking here I'm taking a
goalkeeper from one team and I'm
subtracting a central back from his team
and I'm adding a central back from
another team and what I get is actually
the goalkeeper from the other team and
that's quite amazing for at least for me
to watch Buffon doesn't actually play
for events anymore but this is 2017 data
so that's about like worrying about
relationships in the in the space the
last thing I did is I actually used T's
need to reduce to two dimensions and we
can actually see that we kind of see the
formations of the team here and we can
see the clusters of the different
which are nicely separated and this like
wasn't a really hand-picked it really
does so like that and we can see that
the information that we wanted to embed
really got into the space we found local
really little relationship with
similarity between players and between
players to the generic notes we got long
distance relationship like between a
goalkeeper and his striker to another
striker and another thing to his
goalkeeper which is a similar
relationship and this kind of
information is the exact information
that we already have without we
accumulate you know as we get to know
graphical structures without any need to
of special training but the challenge to
pass this information on into any
downstream models that we are going to
be trained is actually answerable by no
Tyvek before we go into the questions
this is our useful length so the first
one is the original article which is
very friendly to read so I recommend it
it's not like most articles that try to
keep you away the second one is a Python
3 library which is I have written and
implements the notes of a Calgary's and
you can just install by pip install the
third one and the fourth one are
actually a medium post and the notebook
which does all the magic we just talked
about about the FIFA data and the last
one which is really important
you know out of the scope of notes avec
it's a great post that explains the the
rationale and the mechanics of the
skipper model which is behind the words
avec and as far as I can tell is very
critical to understand it so you could
use notes of it and even words effect to
its fullest and that's it any questions
what are the uses of okay the most use
cases that I can think of is when you
want to use the data that is represented
by graphs in downstream tasks you can
think about let's say what they are
doing in the in the in the paper itself
they're using models on top of this to
predict links think about Facebook okay
Facebook has many nodes as people and
links as friends and they might want to
suggest you like who is the most
probable who is the most of all note
that what we wanted to be a friend so
this is one kind of use case another use
case that I actually applied this to was
hierarchy you know there's there's
actually a method to to embed hierarchy
which is called which is like explicit
method to do that which is called the
Poincare embeddings which came out of
Facebook like last year but from what I
could tell and from what I have tested
it actually works better if you just
represent the hierarchy as a graph and
you just embed it and it worked better
but as far as I can bet can tell thank
you very much
[Applause]